[Music]
our political culture has become
intensely polarized and partisan
and that makes it hard to have serious
policy debates each party thinks the
other is the country's biggest problem
so they can't imagine ways to work
together
to address any other problems no amount
of sermonizing about civility could
break this cycle of contempt
instead we need to treat the dysfunction
of our political system
as itself a subject for policy action
that means congress and the president
should look for opportunities to make
incremental reforms to how our
government works
use the lessons of the pandemic to
launch a major reorganization of federal
emergency response by modernizing our
aging public health agencies
and creating a clear division of labor
between washington and the states
or use the occasion of the 2020 census
to launch some reforms of the congress
starting with an expansion of the house
of representatives which could serve as
a catalyst for more changes
we can lower the temperature of our
politics by changing the subject from
who is at fault for our problems
to how do we make things better
after 2020 do you think that
partisanship will get better or worse
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from ai